Speaker 1: OK, let's go next to oh, where
do we go?
How about oh, you know, where let's go to.
I hope I'm pronouncing this correctly.
Is it Coya from Virginia?
Yes, it is.
How are you?
Speaker 6: Very good.
I would say, and you but you sorry, son, you're
doing fine, thank you.
Speaker 1: What's what's going on?
Speaker 6: So I actually had two questions,
if that's all right.
Don't try my best to keep it brief, but
Speaker 1: sure, it'll depend on the duration.
Speaker 6: Yeah, fair enough.
I had a question about the Filibuster and
Pride Month and Black History Month.
First of all, go ahead and start with the
filibuster by.
With the filibuster even on the left, there
is both agreements and disagreements to keep
it, of course, the right one it because then
all the Republicans can continuously block
things as they have for decades now, of course,
but just the same on the left.
The concern is that if we remove the filibuster,
that suddenly Republicans will have a much
easier time pushing legislation as we should
be able to do.
So I was wondering on your thoughts about
that.
Speaker 1: I think that the concern that if
you just destroy the filibuster, it then comes
back and hurts Democrats more than it helps
them.
Today is a completely realistic and practical
concern.
And part of why it's practical and realistic
is that Republicans have shown that they do
not care about how their political maneuverings
are perceived.
Their side will not punish them for doing
one thing when it's Obama's Supreme Court
nominee and a different thing when it's trumps
and then saying if if Biden gets one will
do a different thing again, their side won't
hold them accountable for the dirty tricks
and the hypocrisies and the maneuverings.
So because Democrats have not shown a willingness
to sort of get down in the mud in the same
way, I'm not saying stoop to their level when
it comes to corruption and immorality, but
simply when it comes to doing what you have
to do to get political victories.
I would be very worried that the appeal of
getting rid of the filibuster right now to
get a couple of things passed would disgustingly
backfire in the future, which is why I end
up thinking there should be a reformed filibuster
that requires it to actually be a talking
filibuster.
That will then, as it goes longer and longer,
start to be news and maybe start to have some
political consequences for Republicans, like
really make them work for it.
That's why I end up where I end up versus
just blowing it up altogether.
And it's very practical.
It's I assume because Democrats are so incompetent,
it will backfire against them.
Speaker 6: I see.
So moving on to my second question, regards
to Pride Month and Black History Month, there
always seems to be a lot of corporate interest
involved in that.
And to me, I consider it like it presents
a danger to me and my other fellow community
members, as well as just to even, you know,
straight people.
And this is more of a guard separate history
month.
I'll get on to black history at the moment,
but.
People in the community know usually know
better than to fall for the corporate interests,
that is, put rainbows on everything, sell
it here.
This is how you support the community.
Yet at the same time, none of the proceeds
ever actually go to any.
Communities are not communities.
Any sort of I forgot the word I'm sorry, basically
any kind of causes.
Yes, thank you.
OK, that can actually help people in return
the likes of, you know, suicide hotlines for
trans and gay individuals and so on and so
forth, as well as just, you know, in regards
to even trans surgery, because that stuff
is expensive, especially in America.
It's just they only do it for themselves.
And I wonder what your thoughts are on that
and even in regards to advice that you may
give to other people, because they mainly
prey on straight people who are saying this
is how you can support other LGBTQ members
when
Speaker 1: I've talked to you.
So I have a bunch of segments on this.
I've basically I mean, I've likened it almost
to like a fraud fraud because it is it is
just it it's it's a business decision is all
it is.
And many of these businesses have a long history
of donating to anti-gay politicians while
at the same time celebrating Pride Month.
So, yeah, check out my clips on it.
I've talked about it extensively already.
Thank you.
All right.
Thanks very much.
I'm going to move on because I have so many
people waiting.
I appreciate the call.
We will take a quick break and then we'll
be right back with more in in mere moments.
So if you're holding to talk to me, don't
hang up.